Charles what did it mean to you to bring
Salman Rushdie's book Midnight's
Children to life on the big screen um
well I'm astonished that it's taken so
long I was published in 1981 is 2012 now
and I think is long overdue
and it's been directed by the right
person No and what did it mean to you as
well to have Salman Rushdie not only as
the writer but writing the screenplay er
- um it's quite rare novelists don't
often make the best writers of
screenplays of their own work because
they tend to be too close to it but
that's not the case here it's a terrific
screenplay actually and it's a great
team you know he's an extraordinary
writer and Deepa Mehta is a wonderful
director who tends to literally put her
life on the line when she makes a film -
no she's revered in some circles in
India and absolutely hated and reviled
in other circles because she tends to
upset things rather you know see what
was it like the atmosphere on set then
well it was terrific but we shot it in
Sri Lanka not in India I don't think we
could have made it in India and of
course you're so associated with the
Empire in a wayward jewel in the crown
aren't you again here with Midnight's
Children and and a very different type
of Empire up in between that was 1982 is
now 2012 of course but another Empire in
a way very different one with Game of
Thrones - I mean what can we look
forward to you from your character in
that um more horrid treatment of my
little dwarf son I'm afraid I spend a
lot of time shouting at him and cheating
him appallingly
which is quite upsetting because he's
one of the most delightful men and a
wonderful actor and I just treat him
like dirt it's awful and I think I'm
going to get my comeuppance next year
relish getting into that part for that
particular role um way of thinking yeah
well I do really because it's a great
series it's really really well-written
and they spend money on it really you
know and it's a huge operation you know
we have three full units working the
whole time God knows how many actors and
HBO were on a roll with it it's hugely
successful what favorite moments you
looking forward to bringing to life on a
small screen in the next season of Game
of Thrones um well my favorite moments
with Game of Thrones oh heavens above
probably my death scene that I didn't
know about til somebody in the street
who'd been reading all the books you
know said you've got great death saying
I said Oh have I what is the manner of
my death and he told me it's quite
spectacular ha ha ha I'm not gonna tell
you what it is we look forward to seeing
that Charles
you